let's begin just by saying well we'll do
the tangents faster then we go down to
normals okay so if I point P you
actually have all the tools to your
disposal now to work out well what's the
equation of the tangent at P okay you
could do that but I don't you shout it
out if you're already thinking about it
right you guys know what the parameter
is you know what it actually refers to
so can you take advantage other factly
do you know what the prom is actually
referring to it's not just some random
okay I'll give you a couple minutes all
right you want the equation of the
tangent right so when you know it's a
tangent you know two things immediately
number one it's gonna go through that
point P but secondly you also know
because it's a tangent
it should just touch right what do you
know about the gradient of potential
it's by definition by definition is
going to be a so therefore I'm just
gonna use point gradient for here's my
point in there okay equals no we said
the gradient was P right and then
there's your exponent okay you can just
expand a wee bit you know that expanding
is going to be useful to you
not just because I asked you to get
point sorry praying it intercept form
but also because why might you
anticipate or be useful you've gotten a
P squared over here and you're gonna get
AP squared terms over here as well right
so there's going to be some collecting
of my terms
so I've got P X minus 2 ap square so you
bring that guy over and you get left
with this okay so what can you tell me
about this what seems interesting about
it I can think of two things neither of
them are necessarily obvious but have
staring it with me right
first thing I notice is well it's MX
plus B form right so as we predicted
well not predict it as we make sure
they're gradient is P because by
definition that's what ought to be okay
that's the first thing that I see from
this form something else what does this
mean that looks familiar
that's the it's almost the y-intercept
isn't it it's not quite the one in the
center
sorry it sounds it's the negative of
this right which means that just think
about this for sale right draw this
tangent down right
the higher your point is on the parabola
that will mean ap square gets bigger
right that means the lower down exactly
you say distance
you're way too simple well in this
particular example it is that's just the
coincidence if I drew my my point higher
right there for AP squared over V go
which means that this thing will be
steeper well on its own so therefore my
minus AP squared will be lower in fact
did we exactly the same distance we'll
talk about 90 degrees
curvy later on there are a few there are
a few things and I eat but they will
emerge soon okay so I noticed that this
Y coin is suspicious is one more thing I
noticed I asked you to review the
equation of the corner right up here and
these things are quite similar to each
other do you notice that they're very
very similar to each other in fact ah
so right do you remember I talked about
proving that if you have a radius right
the radius and the tangent at the point
of contact on a circle are what's though
they're they're perpendicular to each
other right and the way that I prove
that to you remember was that I say that
a tangent
attention is the limit of a secant
right so all these two guys right I'll
call it c1 secret to right as they get
closer and closer to Keyon right my two
points of intersection that fall into
secret when they become one they become
a tangent you remember that okay
now exactly the same thing is happening
here because a secant a secret is just
another name for a chord that just keeps
going right so I suppose you could say
this is the equation of
secret right what happens here if I have
Q like over here there goes the court
right if I have Q over here there goes
the court if i qo b er when we draw this
secant like it's starting to look
suspiciously like my tangent right in
fact once q and p sit exactly on top of
each other they are the tangent so
underneath here like you can write with
it this is not just the equation of the
tangent it's also the equation of the
chord which looks like this
ah B plus Q X minus a P Q as Q and P get
closer and closer together
we have language for this when two
things get closer and closer together we
call them limits the limit right as now
you can see in this equation the Q's of
all disappear right so Q is what I want
to turn into P do you see that all right
once Q becomes P this is P plus P which
is 2 P the twos cancel and then over
here this will become P so I see which
is P squared
babe yeah it is right it's the reason
why actually we proved the equation of
the chord before we did the equation of
the tangent
all right last little result that we do
this morning because we're out of time
and will continue this afternoon is the
equation of the normal interests in
limitation because tangent surfs are
awesome - not hard you're going to start
with the same first line with one
difference namely this will be a minus
whatever page minus 1 over P is what you
put in there okay and once you simplify
out this is what you get because of that
multiplication of he across to get rid
of the fractions it doesn't end up being
particularly neat to put it into greater
intercept form like this so this is our
normal equation